[Musique]
ce soir dans notre séquence ping pong je
reçois jean teulé pour son roman le
magasin des suicides paru chez julliard
il va répondre à une critique de jean
charles chapuzet du magazine de
spectacle du monde
j'ai enterré bonsoir bonsoir alors je
vous présente vous êtes écrivain
également cinéaste puisque vous avez
adapté un de vos romans 91
le premier rainbow pour rimbaud
alors vous avez dit sidéré un peu
particulier parce qu'on dit ça peu la
légende est une directrice littéraire
vous ai vu à la télé vous travaillez à
l'époque à canal plus a dit mon nom à 7
ans et c'était à france 2 et c'est vrai
c'est elisabeth gilles qui un jour m'a
appelé en me disant ça fait des années
que j'entends ce que vous dites et à la
télé ça fait des années que je me dis
vous êtes un écrivain qui ne le savaient
pas venez je vous signez un contrat
voilà et c'est comme ça que c'est parti
alors il manque peut-être d'une petite
corps mais on sait jamais parce que ce
livre là pour rendre être l'occasion ce
théâtre est exactement ça c'est le truc
que j'adorerais faire le prochain truc
c'est écrire une pièce de théâtre à sa
dette et à pied incroyable alors ça
peut-être le magasin et des suicides
alors disons de quoi il s'agit alors
annoncées relativement clair là c'est un
petit nom d'une petite entreprise
familiale qui prospèrent depuis quelques
générations
elles vont tout ce qu'il faut pour se
suicider correctement dans les règles de
l'art c'est la famille tuvache voilà
mais il y a dans cette famille
malheureusement quelque chose qui va
survenir l'arrivée d'un certain alan qui
a grand défaut il a une joie de vivre
indécrottable il va tout à pagaille dans
l'organisation de la famille tuvache
surtout c'est exactement ça parce qu'ils
ont un dernier enfant qui n'est hélas
c'est la poisse totale parce
qu'effectivement cette enfant c'est le
bonheur sur pattes et il fout le bordel
dans le magasin dans la famille il
console les clients et l'opère il en
chope une dépression dix ans ce combo me
levais ivan ou couler la boutique
alors on va écouter jean charles
chapuzet parler de vos tech mais je
voudrais dire tout de suite que le
magasin des soucis c'est une façon de
nous prendre conscience de problème
d'une façon différente
alors écoutons ce qu'en dit jean charles
chapuzet
bonsoir jean tenait si je peux me
permettre le suicide mérite mieux
c'est bien écrit mais c'est une grosse
nouvelle c'est sympathique mais ça
mériterait vous alliez plus au fond des
choses vous aborder tous les petits
débats philosophiques propre suicide
mais où les survoler je pense que
lorsque vous confronter la joie de vivre
qu'importe le fils de lucrèce et et
mishima
je pense que j'aurais pu aller plus haut
lucrèce et mishima ccc lucrèce tu vas
chez michou matt stevens qui sont les
parents de la famille tuvache et dans la
famille tuvache ils ont une
particularité six qui donne à tous leurs
enfants des prénoms de suicide est
célèbre
vincent pour pour le fils aîné pour van
gogh marilyn pour boudreau et res
bourges bien voilà il est riche à mal et
voilà en profondeur est vraiment
confrontés deux modes de pensée ou en
tous les cas une dépression d'un côté et
une joie de vivre de l'autre
et alors ça c'est ce que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir fait justement
d'avoir remonté toute cette famille où
il voudrait bien tout se flinguer mais
ils se disent que dans la famille
tuvache on n'a pas le droit de se tuer
parce que sinon qu'ils tiendraient le
magasin alors qu'ils ont bien des
raisons eux aussi de se [ __ ] en l'air
épuisé et puis ce gamin qui est le
bonheur sur pattes donc une loi il me
semblait que j'avais
et fait ce qu'il veut sur le gamin on
continue parce que c'est aussi un
personnage très important puisque c'est
un personnage qui a existé
alan turing ouais alors alan turing
c'est un type formidable c'est pour ça
que les
la femme dans la famille tuvache ils ont
rappelé leur dernier alan c'est parce
que alan turing celle qu'on considère
que c'est l'inventeur de l'ordinateur et
puis il a eu un problème avec son avec
son pays en tout cas il sait innover
pour le dire il a eu un procès pour
homosexualité voilà il ay ay ay là et
ils étaient homosexuels il a eu une
pensée pour nos sexualités
il a été castré chimiquement laissant
lui ont poussé et il a décidé de se
suicider et alors là il a une idée
marrante à 6 il a pris une pomme qui l'a
trompée dans une solution de cyanure
d'apposer sur un guéridon et après un
petit tableau blanc il a peint la pomme
et il a mangé la pomme et il est mort et
au magasin des suicides
ils vendent moi dans mon livre il vend
des kits alan turing c'est-à-dire qu'ils
vendent dans une petite pochette en
plastique la pomme empoisonnée
le tableau blanc les pinceaux de tubes
de couleurs et il demande aux gens de
pain de la pomme et puis et puis de la
bouffe et il précise bien qu'il faut pas
faire le contraire parce que sinon il
n'aurait pas le temps il serait mort lui
aussi il ya le cheat mishima enfants
grave sur le texte en lui-même
à mon sens il y a du bon et du moins bon
moi mon sens il n'y a pas de bonnes
jambes croisées d'abord c'est drôle ça
c'est très bien ça pour quoi ils
s'arrêtent pas là sont mal de toi lui
donnait encore la parole j'aime beaucoup
moins dans ce monde de suicide et que la
discothèque s'appelle kurt cobain que
les russes appellent bérégovoy gérard de
nerval donc le lycée montherlant avec le
personnage s'appelle mishima alors samoa
le monsieur la salle fait pareil mais
moi ça faisait rire que le magasin si
celui-ci surtout se retrouve au
boulevard mérigots voix et tout ça deux
donnant donné que des noms de
de suicide par exemple a même failli
avoir une scène dans une piscine qui
serait appelée la selle la piscine
chaque mayol donc ça aurait pu aurait
été encore pire
on a l'impression quand même que parfois
quand tu dis ça c'est comme si c'était
une mauvaise conscience parce que si on
a une rue bérégovoy
je pense que quand on va passer dans
cette rue là beaucoup de gens ou avoir
des sentiments et j'ai vérifié moi quand
je voulais écrire cette colonie j'allais
chez vérifier si ça existait
effectivement par exemple à nevers il ya
une avenue bérégovoy c'est un petit peu
facile un peu gros et je pense que vous
auriez pu éviter cette facilité bref
c'est surréaliste
et c'est bien vu mais pourquoi pas 300
pourquoi pas 400 pages je voudrais
savoir si c'est par dilettantisme ou six
apart timing éditorial ou tout
simplement si
vous avez eu l'impression de faire le
tour de la question alors en fait si ce
moment et cours effectivement 160 lâcher
parce que ça me semblait pas qu'il y
avait besoin d'en avoir plus et c'est
comme dans les restos même dans les très
bons restos moi j'aime bien ressortir du
réseau avec encore un petit peu faim et
puis surtout moi j'ai écrit ce livre
parce que juste avant j'avais écrit au
verlaine qui faisait dans les 400 pages
fond je françois villon 450 age 2 ans 39
ans de boulot à chaque fois donc là j'ai
vu écrit un livre court qui sans
prétention mais pour me lâcher pour
rigoler voilà tout cas ça laisse jean
charles chapuzet sur sa faim mais sur sa
bonne fin il en vend plus oui ce qui est
bon signe c'est bien sûr en fait il
aurait voulu qu'il y en ait plus puisque
web d'habitude quand j'aime pas un livre
ce que je lui reproche et qu'ils soient
et où qu'ils soient sont toujours trouvé
lundi - également c'est aussi très
pathétique et drôle nature laisse est
réussi mais soyons francs on en retire
rien on passe un bon moment et puis s'en
va son c'est déjà pas mal
et puis en ce moment je trouve que et
c'est pas un reproche que je fais
autre écrivain parce que vraiment chacun
fait absolument ce qu'il veut et
personnes âgées de leçon à donner à
personne mais c'est vrai que la
littérature actuelle en ce moment je la
trouve sombre je la trouve narcissique
bon voilà et ben moi j'avais envie de
faire le contraire d'un livre
délibérément drôle et ça a pas l'air de
déborder dans les librairies et et ça se
passe bien pour lui on lui doit des
écoliers et les libraires et les
les lecteurs ont l'air d'être nombreux
et comptant donc toile à savoir un poil
dans la main cellule en deux heures cet
art tout petit roman que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure plutôt une grosse nouvelle
je crois qu'il faut pas se donner à me
fier si je peux me permettre c'est fait
pour faire rire pour faire pour pourrir
j'avais envie de prendre le sujet le
plus pourri du monde le plus le plus
plombé les gens qui se tuent que des
gens
dans leur vie et envie de descendre du
train au cours de voyages tellement ils
ont trouvé que cette vie et pas
intéressante chauffe pas ça drôle
mais justement il faut il me semble
qu'il faut rire sur les choses qui nous
terrifie qu'il est heureux terrorisme
mois ggd
j'ai eu des gens dans ma famille qui
sont suicidés et et ça m'a pas fait rire
mais mais justement c'est une façon de
dédramatiser tout ça le terme de les
remiser est ce que vous auriez écrit la
dernière petite gorgée de bière non mais
bp baby ceci dit delerm chercher
absolument rien contre il a sa place
comme tout le monde et puis qui chauffe
c'est pas défaut d'être des delerm bbb
mais je le serai pas parce que le
prochain roman fera sûrement dans les
400 pages en tout cas on l'attend ce
monsieur dans le montespan ça va
s'appeler passion du jour la montespan
alors assez l'oeuf entier soit nommé
s'intéressant aussi dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui parce que c'est pas si
facile d'être le mari d'une dame qui est
dans la lumière devant soi là alors donc
on parlait ce soir donc de jean teulé le
magasin des suicides paru chez julliard
comme tous vos romans parce que vous
êtes fidèles en matière de littéraire et
un dernier petit coucou jean charles
chapuzet que quand même on sent qu'il a
aimée souliers moi je trouve que ce
monsieur tout à fait sympathique et moi
je suis tout à fait prêt à déjeuner avec
lui à parler de n'importe quoi et il a
le droit et c'est normal jean teulé
invite jean charles chapuzet et ils
peuvent par le cours d'un repas de le
magasin des suicides paru chez julliard
jean merci beaucoup merci beaucoup merci
daurade
[Musique]